foreign
[Music]
[Music]
poland
does not like to show its international
solidarity the polish people have proven
that to be false
in the last 100 days
[Music]
and poland can now be
proud because you are
an example to the rest of the world an
example
of freedom
of equality of solidarity
[Music]
and we must keep equality at the
forefront of all our actions
[Applause]
[Music]
today the most important that should be
the priority is european union
because we are in the
big danger and
[Music]
russian policy is very much against our
values against the west against the
european union as well so the unity is a
precondition of of success and the same
appeal i have to the polish government
this government which is eurosceptical
that's true should eliminate should
cancel all these elements which can
destroy this european unity and can
destroy good cooperation between poland
and eu
young people connected people fighting
for women's rights fighting for lgbtiq
rights fighting for
uh climate change to do something and
i'm so much having trust in these
fantastic people poland has different
faces and poland has this smiling face
not the sad face of kaczynski that this
smile
describes our dreams of living in the
free country which we were fighting for
so long a country of solidarity country
of respecting human rights women's
rights minority rights that
this dream is unstoppable and i hope
they will take it home and i hope we as
pose we will never
stop dreaming